hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics
and uh lately we had some moonies come
and visit us
munis are people who believe that we
have not gone to the moon
they begin with that assumption okay or
they
this is their theory we never went to
the moon
uh
and we had um
several of them you know put comments
but none of them addressed
or or a few of them if anything
if anyone addressed uh some of the
issues of physics okay and that's what
we would like to do in this channel we
we like to do a little more physics and
less
politics less conspiracy theory there is
some conspiracy theory involved but
primarily it should be physics okay
and uh so you know there are different
levels of belief
of
uh
what people
think happened okay
and some people accept that we went into
space but not to the moon
others don't believe we went to the
space at all
i guess others are out there and they
don't even believe that nasa exists or
you know there's no nasa center at
control center in houston no cape
canaveral no kate kennedy or kennedy
center you know i mean you know some you
have all these different levels of
belief
and uh and assumptions you know where
they start out from and so the issue is
that you know you have to address each
one of these levels
and
what i
want to do you know in in this channel
on the issue of the moonies is that you
know for those of those who are sitting
on the fence
you know at least i want them to fall
over on certain things which i think
that they can show to themselves okay if
they're honest with themselves okay and
again they put the seed of doubt in my
mind i i
used to believe 100 that we went to the
moon there are some issues now that i
cannot answer
and because of that i have to withhold a
little bit of belief okay
i have to make a certain assumptions
and above all you know i i need to look
at this
objectively okay and that's what i want
to do
anyways
one of the ways i i want to do this is
by something that
almost anyone can verify out there and
that is the iss the international space
station okay
and here you see uh
this iss
according to official versions it was
built in several steps okay
and uh over a period of ten years
they used the
different programs to get things up
there the shuttles the russians also
sent probes out there and they built
this little by little okay
one piece at a time again over 10 years
as they needed it and they had to work
out there in the middle of nowhere with
no gravity
and so the question is you know is this
does this exist
uh does is is there such a thing as the
iss floating out there
some people say no
there's no such monster out there
floating in space orbiting the earth
so is it a fact
and a person uh raised an issue and he
says the following he says
a fact
is correct
that is correct
but if you look at the word correct you
know it's just an opinion what is
correct to you is incorrect to someone
else
and uh you know opinions that's religion
that's just a belief that's how
everybody thinks things are for
themselves okay and
using a different uh
account he goes in there says a belief
has absolutely no credence
inside in the scientific method
so uh you know he has it that a fact is
correct and he says it has nothing to do
with the scientific method because
that's what uh you know a fact is a
belief someone believes that this is a
fact and not that right
and then he says everything is energy
that can neither
uh be created nor destroyed is a fact
so i guess
again he all he did was chase his tail
around you know all he did was say a
fact is a belief an opinion and energy
is a fact meaning it's a
an opinion his opinion i guess that's
what he believes in
and then he says it's got nothing to do
with science
okay good
i'm glad he went uh completely around
anyways um
here we have a uh
a fact okay more facts
are any of these facts okay we add them
to his list okay
is one plus one equal to a fact
you know and the issue there is that um
two
is is just a number and we're defining
the word two
we're defining it as one plus one it's
only a definition that you're staring at
there you know how many times you're
going to move your hand up and down
counting you know one two
want the number three you can't you move
your hand three times and you call that
a three that's a definition it's a
tautology
okay so to say that um
you know that one plus one equals two is
a fact you know it's just a tautology
um how about pi the number pi is that
you know we have a
a ratio between two lengths
is that a fact or is that a tautology
how about god exists is that a fact
fact for whom
some people believe god exists other
people say there is no such thing as god
and so and they all say they know
we know
okay that god exists the other guy said
i know god doesn't exist so does god
exist is that a fact uh bend time equal
to gravity you know it's been time
gravity is that a fact
has it been proven and accepted by every
person on earth okay
santa claus uh rides a slave on
christmas
you ate yesterday maybe you didn't eat
yesterday i don't know that you say it's
a fact
you know
i don't believe you i don't believe it's
a fact okay you will eat tomorrow
well we don't know uh until we get there
we won't know if it's a fact will we
napoleon waterloo
is that a fact okay and so again we have
all these things which we take for facts
turns out when you look deep you know we
don't know napoleon went to waterloo all
we know we know for a fact is that um
it's in the history books we just have
to memorize it
is a fact what you memorize
and believe
because you just memorized it for the
test or for whatever the best your exam
to graduate
okay and uh so yeah think about all that
uh here's the uh
what i was showing about the iss
i'm saying it is a fact
and
yeah when we talk about facts and we're
talking about evidence we're talking
about religion okay we don't present
evidence in science
we do it in religion why because we're
trying to persuade people to change
their minds okay we're trying to
convince them we're trying to recruit
them to our way of thinking that's what
evidence is used for so evidence plays
no part in science it only plays
a role in religion and here's a
an amateur i showed the other day okay
and the guy is filming the iss
okay and there he takes a picture of
that so you know you can
make that even bigger if you want and
what he's showing is that he can film
the iss out there at night okay
so he's saying the iss is out there he's
not the only amateur there's hundreds of
amateurs who
film this and have hit film that they
upload their videos and so on in
pictures so you know uh
the question is
whether there is something out there and
some people deny that there is an iss
out there and i showed the other day
that inside the iss you know you have
this fellow and he's floating around
with his little laptop and people think
a lot of people think that this is all
done with green screen
and uh wires
uh photoshop maybe you know
and this guy i want to clarify he's been
on there uh he uh talking here in this
uh
little video he he was talking for 45
minutes yeah he was showing us the whole
place i just
took a little chunk of it to show you
and i'm saying this is real and if you
can see them floating uh you know if you
think that's done with wires well i
don't know what to say to you you know
you got a problem
okay so um i showed the iss the fellow
filming it out there in space he takes a
picture of it okay
it's it's you can tell by the distance
that you can show with you know with
your own binoculars or with your
telescope or whatever you've got or your
friends you know
that it's out there and these guys are
floating out there because they're 400
kilometers away from the earth
and they're in zero essentially zero
gravity maybe there's some gravity there
but it's a lot less than here on earth
so the guy's floating he's being filmed
inside the
you know this uh this iss
building that they built out there over
10 years
so he's there he's there floating and
these people don't believe they say all
this was done in hollywood okay so we
have a problem we have to start with
those people you know people who who
you know don't even accept something as
basic as the iss i mean if the iss
weren't there we'd have a big problem
bringing evidence that we ever went into
space that we set rockets into space or
to the moon or to whatever here we're
talking about something that you can
verify today
that's where the difference is that's
why the iss is a good place to start for
all those extreme moonies people who
take it to the other extreme right
and uh so one fell out there here's what
he said he said iss is a hoax and he
talks about the facts and he goes over
all these facts uh that he thinks or
that are facts for his understanding for
him right and he's saying oh these prove
that there is no iss
you know to me it's a it's uh it's a
case of um
of just extreme mooney okay this fellow
doesn't want to accept that there's this
thing flying out there when he can just
show it
with a telescope or with a with a
pair of binoculars
and look at here
uh here this is what i think this is
it's a case of you know what happened to
galileo that the cardinals didn't want
to look through his telescope apparently
right i guess the way they saw it is now
you gotta look through the microscope at
scriptures
and uh if you look at scriptures you'll
find that it says there's only seven
uh objects out there and that's it no
galilean moons you know and again all
this fellow has to do is go to a
telescope go to a pair of binoculars
look out there the schedule for the iss
passing through different countries uh
it goes around the earth 15 times a day
okay so you should like every 90 minutes
and so
the issue is all you have to do is get a
pair of binoculars look out there when
it comes over your house and you'll see
it we're done that's how simple it is
you don't need to put all these
facts
and say well you know these are the
facts well these are the facts that he
believes because again he what he has is
belief okay that's what it's all about
and um
uh here's a
a word that you may want to look up okay
which is when you're seeing something
okay
and you're seeing you're hearing it
and you don't believe your eyes or your
ears and instead you accept what someone
else is feeding you
a lie that someone is feeding you it's
known as gaslighting okay
it's making someone question his own
reality
okay
the guy has arguments and he convinces
you
despite that your eyes and your ears
tell you something different so you
don't believe your own
senses in other words right
and uh it comes from a
movie uh that was shown in 1944 actually
it comes from four years earlier a movie
made by the british
with the same name and same theme okay
so the
movie was named gaslight okay because
the guy was trying to fool his wife into
believing she was crazy and so on did it
with the gaslights the uh
action takes place in 1860s when they
had these gas lights so he turns them on
and off and so on makes her think that
she's crazy
okay so it's known as gaslighting it's
misleading
people into believing something that
ain't true that is obviously
patently not true because you're staring
at it so why would someone believe in
the opposite when you're staring and
hearing at
you know something different something
that your senses tell you is not what
this guy is telling you
and the most famous uh case that we have
of gaslighting i guess you could say uh
in the last 20 years
is uh what happened on 9 11 world trade
center seven
okay
and i want you to listen
and see
okay look with your eyes listen with
your ears
what uh you see and hear objectively
forget about all your preconceptions
okay and here it goes okay let me put it
on here it goes
i remember getting a call from the fire
department commander
telling me that they were not sure
they're going to be able to contain the
fire
i said you know we've had such terrible
loss of life
maybe the smartest thing to do is pull
it
uh and they made that decision to pull
and then we watched the building
collapse
the colony made that decision to pull
the decision to pull decisions to pull
do you hear that if you're on
the flame
debris coming down
it's gone man
[Music]
that information of course take a look
at that right hand side of the screen
it's going down right now there it is
yep go down right there
so uh was the demolition of world trade
center seven a fact
or
or should you be gaslighted and think
that it was you know what they tell you
uh the other version that they tell you
about it okay
so you gotta tell me which one is true
okay either it's a fact it happened it
was demolished or what debris brought it
down
which is the fact
and uh why am i bringing that up because
again people talk about facts in science
and for that we have to look at the
definition
is
uh
fact
uh part of science
and here we go okay
here we have uh the definitions that
you'll find in the dictionary and the
wikipedia
and there you see effects something that
actually exists reality truth whatever
that is
and
the next one is interesting is something
known to exist like for example the iss
something you can show to yourself that
exists right now or to have happened
past tense like world trade center seven
i mean you know we can't reproduce world
trade center seven again
any way you want to look at it but you
know it's a different story from the iss
that's something you can look up there
and verify with your own eyes
okay so i'm just trying to separate
these different types of facts to exist
and to have happen are two different
aspects and the question is whether any
of those have anything to do with
science okay
and uh there you can see some of the
definitions and you can see that
none of these words are ever defined
scientifically uh truth is what true
true state of matter uh or the character
being true
and it's a fact and what is the fact
fact is true okay and there you see it
on the right fact something that is true
what is truth the property of being in
accord with fact
and this is what you get you don't have
any definitions any scientific
definitions much less can you use the
word fact in science
you can't bring that word into science
because there is no such thing as
scientific fact
okay and here's a rundown of that okay
fact is an opinion a belief
part of religion has nothing to do with
science okay there are no facts in
science okay what we have in science is
known as statement
of the facts
you give a statement of what you think
is the fact are the facts uh the
prosecutor goes in there he's trying to
prove his case to the jury
again fact has to do with belief and he
presents his case he said these are the
facts
then the defense attorney goes up there
and he has a different set of facts one
guy believes
the defendant is guilty and the other
one believes the defendant is innocent
okay and they both present the facts
yeah sure and what does the jury
conclude again they only conclude with
belief they don't know what the facts
really are they just say well
what i heard makes me believe in this
direction the other guy says i believe
in that direction okay so facts
have nothing to do with science
and you know people should take that
word out of their mouth stop talking
about facts okay
um the opponent may proceed with
different set of facts and the juror
takes the assumptions at face value in
other words when the when the prosecutor
says these are the facts okay no these
are the effects according to him it's a
statement of the facts and the jury
doesn't have to believe those so-called
facts what the jury does is listens
concedes the facts in order to
understand what his case is all about
what his theory is
that's the way it works in science okay
so no we don't believe in facts we don't
introduce facts what we do is we make a
statement of the facts that's part of
what is known as the assumptions
and you concede those
statements of the facts in order to
understand the theory founded upon that
mother nature is the only or god or the
devil whoever
they know the facts they know what
happened they have this filing cabinet
and they have all the things that ever
happened
but we have no access to those cabinets
those are the facts we can only make
statements of the facts of what we think
happened okay
and uh there are different aspects of
facts that we should take into
consideration and these are the
notions okay we have static versus
dynamic facts
we have object versus occurrence you
know a thing versus something that
occurred happened okay we have issue of
time you have future and past okay and
then you have something like known as
the present which we're going to be
dealing with today in fact okay
and uh here's uh
examples of static versus dynamic okay
um all atoms are physically
interconnected by electromagnetic ropes
is that a fact
uh
will you be required to believe it
no you concede the assumption in order
to understand the theory found it upon
it that's the way it works it's not a
question for you to believe because
we're not asking you to believe we're
saying let us assume
that all
atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected that's the way it works
uh the wall is red
well you're staring at the wall it's red
obviously it's it's there right
well yeah
but you know one guy might say well it's
what is red
the guy said well 620 nanometers
uh frequency
and the other guy might say well that's
621 well let's measure it and they spend
all day long with measuring and they say
well it's 620 and so many decimal points
and they can argue all day long whether
the wall is red okay
so
is the wall
red
620 nanometers as mother nature
understands it or is it the best reading
we can get
you know on the color of the wall and
the frequency coming from the wall
and so again uh
it all comes down to belief okay
um
any ratio okay and those are static
notions how about the uh dynamic ones
you know acceleration of gravity you let
go of the spoon right
and uh it falls at a certain rate and we
say 9.8 meters per second square okay
that's the rate at which it falls
is that a fact
how much of it is a fact do we have to
go to gazillion decimal points to find
out exactly at what rate it falls
is that a question of
accuracy of precision
okay and so on down the line i mean you
know uh does light travel 300 000
kilometers per second one guy says it's
299.99
the other guy might say 301
okay so and other people don't believe
it's a constant
they say no light varies
in fact uh one of those uh
were was einstein because he had light
curve
around uh warp space time
and then he said well in the fourth
dimension it goes straight here it
curves
okay
and uh yeah one plus one equals two
that's just uh
you know it's a static
concept in a way you know always
actually it's dynamic because you're
moving your arm to count each number
okay
so you know
what are these um
these facts well you have again static
versus dynamic okay
and here's uh
here's the timeline the past and present
okay
okay here we have the future versus the
past you know haley's comment well it
involves both the past and the future we
saw it in the past or some people saw it
and they say well it's going to come
back in what 75 76 years
well will it is that a fact
how about an eclipse you know the moon
goes in front of the earth and the sun
between them
will that happen tomorrow or the next
year or whatever
are those facts what if something
destroys the moon and doesn't become a
fact in the future
okay and so you can go on and on you
know uh will the sun shine tomorrow well
we have we're 99.99999
[Music]
sure that it will come up tomorrow
but you don't never know maybe something
destroys the sun tomorrow maybe it blows
up maybe you don't come up tomorrow and
you don't see the sun come up so
for you it's not a fact
uh will you eat tomorrow well i don't
know maybe you will how about did you
eat yesterday well i don't know if it's
a fact maybe you were not on a diet you
didn't eat the whole day
did johnny die
okay uh
well we don't know maybe he's just
missing he will johnny
dies someday
well everybody would say yes but then
you say well humanity
will it die someday will it become
extinct someday
what made you change your mind here and
say well i don't know if humanity will
die
i mean isn't the same thing as johnny
what is johnny johnny is a system of
cells humanity is a system of people
made of cells
why would humanity live forever and
johnny not live forever okay
okay and uh so we get to the present and
here
this is where i want to con to conclude
okay
the present you have location so
therefore you exist by definition
because exist is an object
okay that has location you don't have
location you don't exist god wants to
exist first he's got to be an object
he's got to be a thing he's got to have
shape and then he had better have
location there had better be distance
straight line of direction between god
and me i don't care what dimension
uh god wishes to hide there should be a
straight line of direction from god to
me okay
and
you are alive
okay why because you move against
gravity that's the definition of living
anything that moves against the path of
least resistance right and primarily
gravity
and then the
the one that you can prove to yourself
in the present tense right which we'll
be talking about today which is the iss
is there an iss out there
okay and all you have to do is look
through the telescope pay attention to
galileo he says you must look through
the telescope if you want to see the
moons the galilean moons well this is no
different if you want to know if the iss
is out there don't conjecture don't go
in there and say give me all the reasons
why the iss
is not out there just take your
binoculars and point them at
the sky all you have to do is
lift your face a little bit and just
stare
that's all it takes
okay we had this follow and
he um
he criticized the scientific method that
we have here he doesn't like it
and he went over different aspects of it
and we're going to answer some of his
inquiries his questions right
and here's one okay
this is what he said he was talking
about whether science is
about
studying
and whether science has to do with
knowledge
and whether um
you
test the hypothesis as we covered the
other day but then whether um
you know these uh these uh science
is is about getting a degree
is is that what science is about
studying getting a degree collecting
knowledge and learning from our mistakes
is that what it is is science an ongoing
process
okay
and here's what he's had to say his own
words okay so here it is pay attention
give me a second here
here it goes
questions and issues addressed in this
rebuttal include
is science about learning by rote
is science about accumulating knowledge
and
does science progress through trial and
error
to graduate you need to show that you
have an understanding of what you have
been taught now to answer the question
of what happens if you obtain no
knowledge well that's a tricky one
because you should obtain at least a
tiny amount of knowledge even if the
knowledge that is obtained is the thing
you are doing isn't working
there is still some knowledge yeah it
may not necessarily be the knowledge
that you're after but science is all
about trial and error if something
doesn't work well you now know that it
doesn't work so go back to the drawing
board and try something different it is
very difficult for me to think of a
scenario in which you wouldn't actually
gain any knowledge unless of course
you're doing absolutely terrible science
terrible science yeah i agree with him
you know terrible science what is
terrible science well let's find out uh
i don't know where this fellow studied
maybe studied at harvard or cambridge
one of those monasteries
and maybe he was a choir boy he was
required to memorize
everything that was fed to him and
that's what he regurgitated let's find
out what terrible science is okay so he
says terrorist of all sciences or
you know what we say here terrible
science is what he mentioned there
graduates
must show that they
can regurgitate what they memorize by
from the previous generation
is that what science is you sit down you
open a book you memorize what's in the
book which is what people from the
previous generation wrote
you memorize it regurgitate it for the
test get a degree
that's science
studying
memorizing is that how science
progresses is that what he calls
studying
just memorizing
science he says is knowledge we say it's
got nothing to do with knowledge now
people raise the
um
issue the argument that that's what it's
always been the word science comes from
the
latin meaning
syria meaning knowledge
and the question is uh first of all
etymology has
you know
we don't use that in science because
that's just history that's just you know
the origin of a word you know they could
have misdefined it from the start
okay that's one issue the other one is
that you know we we change definitions
whenever we find something wrong with
them over the ages we don't rely on
history and say that's that's what
science was from the beginning and
that's how we have to keep it today in
fact
uh
in the 17th century they changed the
notion of science which they called
natural philosophy and they said look
there was a problem with with the greeks
uh-huh what was the problem well the
problem was that they didn't run
experiments to test their hypothesis
okay
so so the greeks did not test the
hypothesis and so they changed the
notion of science they say no
science you need to introduce
experiments
and you have to emphasize math you need
to have equations and so on and so they
changed the the direction of science in
the direction of math and what they did
was describe the experiments that they
ran and come up with an equation they
said okay that's science science is an
equation that describes
how something occurred meaning
what happened but only a description of
it mathematica a quantitative
description of it
and to date to this day we have no
explanations
that's the problem okay we have no
rational explanations
for any phenomenon especially that's
invisible intangible okay that's that's
where we're at so it doesn't matter that
the etymology takes you back to the word
syria which is knowledge if
we redefine words when we find something
wrong with them
and the question is whether knowledge
has anything to do with science and no
knowledge when you know something you
believe it
the other guy believes something
different
you believe that god exists you know god
exists the other guy knows that god
doesn't exist so who's right which one
is the fact again you know if everybody
knows things which are opposites
contradictory and then no uh we don't um
do trial and error in science
essentially we have to explain something
you can do all the trial and error you
want in your
dark basement when you come to the
conference we need for you to explain
what you learned what your conclusions
are from from your experiments but to do
an experiment anybody can do an
experiment here i'll do an experiment
which i always do here very important
experiment i let go with a pencil
okay and it falls to earth there's your
experiment let's do it twice so it's
repeatable so it's scientific right
there it goes again okay now i did the
experiment was that science
what did i learn that a pencil falls
we call that science doing experiments
and describing it quantitatively like
you know what the uh acceleration of
gravity is
what what rate it fell
is that science
you know that's like saying i measure a
table measured one meter one meter and
one millimeter because i measured it
more precisely
and you get a nobel prize for that you
because you measured something and put
it into an equation
is that science
so no uh science is not by trial and
error technology which is by trial and
error we do not do experiments in
science what we do in science we explain
experiments how they happen what what
caused them to happen that's what we do
in science but we don't do experiment
the experiments what the technician or
you know the operator does he he goes uh
and does the experiment brings the data
back to the
engineer or to the scientists and that's
the guy that's gonna figure out how it
happened or you know what actually
happened
but to do an experiment is not science
you go to the lab you mix two liquids it
was blue now it turns red
you don't understand why
but you did the experiment
and you can see what rate it when you
know
so many seconds it turned you know red
or blue or whatever
is that science
just
you know it's what uh ernest rutherford
called uh stamp
collecting science is not stamp
collecting you don't just collect data
and bring it in and say i did science
because i did an experiment and
collected all this data and have the
equation to show for it
so
here's genuine science and comparison
okay science is objective
its purpose its goal is to understand
how the universe works
for that you need to you know understand
gravity you need to understand uh
magnetism electricity what the atom
looks like you need to look at you need
to discover you need to try to explain
the invisible world of mother nature's
and father universes
you can't it's the visible stuff and
tangible stuff that we have figured out
we haven't figured out the intangible
invisible stuff that's where the problem
is
and in science we must explain and read
and uh regurgitate what the previous
generation
feed us is not science
okay
so uh let's get science right on the
right track what this fellow who was
doing was not science what what he said
is science that's not science okay here
we have uh examples of that here's uh
gravity uh according to general
relativity is this science okay we have
uh the earth and the moon flying around
it and they're both
going around the sun
okay and so
why doesn't the earth fly away
and so the answer that these people give
you is that uh time is warped
or what this fellow said the other day
time is bent
okay so time has been what are we saying
bending the seconds the minutes the
hours
so we have a problem because this is an
irrational explanation that general
relativity has and which has fed to the
world
this is not rational at all so this is
not an explanation it's not a physical
interpretation for how gravity works how
the universe works okay
here's a
light okay
what is light well they say it's a wave
packet okay what's a wave packet and
this is what they draw this is what they
show you this is a wave package you're
staring at it
this nonsense this little squiggly
little thing that moves what is that
what are we staring at
here what is this nonsense but this is
the way they they illustrate it okay
and uh just in case if you don't believe
in this you can go always to the nobel
prize winners and here's a nobel prize
winner and his name is roger penrose he
won the nobel prize the other day okay
and what did he draw he's the guy who
invented the penrose staircase by the
way and he
draws this in his book a wave packet
that's where i got it got it from his
book it's that's a wave packet what is
that uh robin hood's arrow
with a squiggly
whatever around it that's a wave packet
is this what light is
i mean show me the mediator of light and
they say it's a wave pack and that's
what they draw
it's ridiculous
but this is what people swallow and they
say oh it's okay i have no problem with
it
here's the atom okay
this is the one that they use
the planetary model they have uh
three quarks in the center they're
held by gluons which are bed springs
that are somehow vibrating they have
this blue electron ball going around and
it falls from one level to another and
rises from one level to another energy
levels whatever those are
and uh and the question is wasn't why
does that little blue ball fly away
spontaneously why does it fall to the
nucleus
i mean it doesn't do either it just goes
from one level to another back and forth
what by miracle i mean what's what's the
explanation for it that's what these
people have to answer
okay and no they just feed it to you and
people believe it and they have to use
that model
to explain for example electricity
because what is electricity well here it
is you see electricity also there is the
explanation it's a bunch of electron
balls
okay that fly fly from one atom to the
next
so if this is electricity you have to
rely on the planetary model which i just
showed
okay and again the question is why
doesn't the electron spontaneously
fly away okay that's what you have to
answer if you cannot answer that
question you don't even have a starting
point you cannot even begin your
presentation say look let me explain
electricity to you let me explain
ionization to you let me explain the
quantum jump to you you cannot do any of
those because you're going to rely on
the planetary model which you at the end
of your presentation say oh by the way
we don't believe in our own planetary
model that's not the model of the atom
then why did you use it to explain
electricity quantum jump and
you know um
ionization why did you use that model
show me the real model show me your atom
before you begin after all a lot of
people out there claim that they
photographed and filmed with the
atomic force microscope
with the scanning electron microscope
they filmed and interviewed every single
electron every proton
so if that's the case you should not be
able you should not have any excuse
not to draw to illustrate for me an atom
a hydrogen atom will do all i need is to
see your little atom is it a proton with
a little electron bead next to it is
that your atom
okay i mean you can't say well we don't
know what it looks like we've never seen
that far well you did or you did you
either filmed it and photographed it or
you did that's one issue the other one
is okay so even if you
uh filmed and photographed it just
explain to me why the electron bead
doesn't fly away that's how simple it is
and uh finally here we have magnetism
and for that we have to look at what
this uh fellow from ucla he's a
professor
okay he's a phd okay that's what you're
gonna be listening to
and he's gonna explain how a magnet
attracts another he's gonna boast
because they know it all okay okay so
what is he gonna explain he's gonna
explain that the electrons in each
magnet
you know spin in the same direction
that's what he's gonna say
okay even if that's the case how does
that produce attraction between two
magnets or repulsion between two magnets
that's the issue so let them let's hear
him first okay
you'll hear his own version i sped it up
here okay just so that you can uh listen
to it in fast motion here it is one
magnet either repels
or attracts another and nobody knows why
except you
after watching today's video one way to
understand magnets is through magnetic
domains
it was discovered that electrons had a
property called spin
that is the electron was spinning as it
circled the nucleus
it's the alignment these electrons spins
that results in the magnetic properties
of iron these atoms have an unusual
double valence in which their two
valence electrons are paired with
parallel spins in summary a magnet is a
collection of microscopic crystal
domains that have their electron spins
aligned this is particularly prevalent
in iron nickel and cobalt in which there
is a pair of valence electrons with
their spins aligned
i like how these people are so arrogant
they know it all they know it all and
they talk about spin when first spin is
not spin okay
uh particle is not a particle in quantum
mechanics
they use these words like particle and
spin and people say well i know what a
particle is i know what a spin is it's
like you spin a top
no it ain't
the spin in quantum they don't even know
how to define it they just say it's a
property of an electron that's all they
say but then they use the word spin when
they're trying to give you an
explanation like this one they say well
it spins the atoms and you say okay i
understand what spin is no that's not
what it is in quantum mechanics spin is
not like a top spinning
okay and so they use these words and
they mislead the public
and and they mislead even the students
you know people who are going to
graduate and graduate in
in quantum mechanics and whatever and so
the particle's not a particle because
it's not the classical particle it's not
a little ball which is what they
illustrate and move around
then they say well a particle's not a
particle a particle is a
wave function
what do you mean it's a waveform what is
a wave function yeah it's a collapse you
know it collapsed
and then it spins what spins do you mean
it twirls around no no that's not spin
in quantum what is squint oh we don't
know
and so he used a spin and okay let's
concede let's concede so the electrons
are spinning in this magnet in in this
other magnet how does that attract two
magnets
and here's the analogy okay here
this is the analogy you have a wagon two
wagons really and the melons the
watermelons are spinning in the same
direction tell me how
that attracts the two carts together
okay here it is
okay so you have the melon the
watermelons okay and they're spinning
okay great they're spinning in the same
direction from above you can say they're
spinning clockwise in both carts how
does that bring the two carts together
that's what i want you to tell me
uh you don't like them spinning in the
same direction okay we'll make one of
them spin in the opposite direction if
that helps at all i don't know you tell
me
so how
how does that bring the fact that the
watermelons you know the electrons are
spinning in each magnet how does that
attract or repel two magnets what is the
mechanism
to say that you know the
electrons are spinning and brings two
magnets together
you know you don't have a mechanism
and so you know these people say we know
it we know
they use that word no it's a fact that
we proved it
we have evidence
and then you they come up with this
nonsense they say well the electrons
spin in each magnet in the same
direction okay so they spin assuming you
know assuming electrons are particles
assuming they spin none of which is true
because particles ain't particles and
spin ain't spin okay let's concede and
how does that bring the two magnets
together
and yeah you can wait 100 years for it
so these people they they talk about you
know
uh knowledge that they know
and that they've proven through
experiments that they tested the
hypothesis and then they come up with
this irrational poppycock
okay so so you tell me if they have the
right scientific method
okay let's get on to the subject matter
of today
and that is motion
what is motion has anybody any idea what
motion is
you know and motion has been talked
about since
days of old at least since the days of
the greek and i'm sure that the greece
did not come up with all this on their
own i think they inherited a lot of the
stuff from perhaps the egyptians uh
persians maybe the sumerians i think all
that was passed on
from one generation to the uh next from
one empire to the next and um and
we got ours primarily from the greeks
because they formalized it then because
their records survived okay
okay so here we have uh perhaps the most
uh
thorough uh researcher in in this matter
uh he's called a philosopher i don't
think they were philosophers at all
philosophy is something else but his
name is aristotle okay and so this is
what in a nutshell i mean you gotta read
the book and go into more detail to to
get to the bottom of it but this gives
you a snapshot of how aristotle was
thinking or not
this out of his book physics
approximately 350 bc okay motion
fulfillment of what exists potentially
he says you have
potentiality something
that can become something different in
the future okay and he says it has this
uh potential
and when it's fulfilled when the
potential is fulfilled he calls that
motion that was his reasoning okay
that's how that's how he defined it okay
he can continue he said well motion is
continuous
okay what do you mean by continuous like
you know no interruptions what no
exactly the opposite the word continuous
according to
aristotle or his
translator which i which you also have
to look at right
continues is what is infinitely
divisible
meaning if you can chop it into pieces
then it's continuous
and
we have a different definition of
continuous continuous is that which is
made of a single piece
that's continuous not if it's chopped
into segments that is not continuous
okay segments are not continuous i mean
each segment could be if they're it's
made of a single piece but a series of
segments is not continuous but that's
the notion they had and so he had this
notion that motion
was chopped into pieces
what pieces
voids which they called
places
they called it voids as well but today
the word that would be used for that is
position okay so they had all these
positions or locations you could even
use right they called it void or it was
translated as void or places so what is
motion made of
motion is made of chunks
of places of voids
of locations of positions
and so he calls that continuous
okay because he says continuous is what
you can chop up into little pieces
okay
why he was thinking of the number line
because they're going to put numbers or
think of it in terms of numbers that
they're going to put a number per
location
uh maybe
a an ordered pair
right
okay
so this this is where all this went it
went into mathematics okay they started
putting
numbers
to locations and they started talking
about motion in terms of location
meaning
displacement
distance traveled
to which one they're going to put a
number so many meters what is a meter
made out of well centimeters millimeters
you know micrometers etc
okay and then he says
time indeed and movement are infinite
okay
uh no the word is not infinite again
poor language maybe it's poor
translation maybe they had the right
idea maybe the translator did it wrong
no infinite is an adjective you do not
use it to
qualify motion
okay so you cannot say that motion is
infinite time is infinite it's
irrational you're using an adjective to
qualify a concept that's irrational in
science okay you can use adjectives like
black or or whatever to qualify an
object a thing you can say that object
that table is black or brown or whatever
you can say that that that you can use
an adjective for but you can't say that
the table is infinite first of all you
cannot say a table is infinite because
all objects are finite it's that which
has shape and then if it's an infinite
table it means
what that uh
there's nothing outside of it meaning
you cannot even imagine that it's an
object so infinite object
is a
an oxymoron it destroys itself okay
okay so uh in book three he says motion
is change of play i'm sorry book four he
says motion is change of place
meaning you're gonna go from one
location to another
that's pretty much the definition that
we have today two or more locations
that's correct okay but uh it's like you
know they don't listen to what they're
saying
they don't even pay attention to what
they're saying they say a change of play
but then we have a problem first of all
because motion is change
and change is motion you can't have
change without motion
therefore you cannot use the word change
ever to define motion
which is how it's defined today if you
look up the word motion anywhere say
change of location change a place or
change something you can't use the word
change because change is motion you're
saying motion is motion that's all you
said you use the synonym to define
define
with quotation circular definition
that's what a synonym is you use a
synonym to define motion you can't do
that
okay it says a body moves from place to
place again he has this notion
that
motion is a body a thing
a figure as uh euclid would call it a
figure moving from one location from one
void to another okay this was the notion
they had okay motion therefore is
infinitely divisible why because it's
made out of pieces right into discrete
places locations
okay so this is the notion with which we
started this is the one we inherited
okay did we do any better
uh no because as you
i talked about the other day you know
all the way up to
good ol um
newton girl newt what did newt define
well he said i don't define motion
because everybody knows what it is
so nobody defined motion to this day
and this is very easily yeah people
sometimes say we have we have i have a
definition for the word object i have a
definition for the word motion and they
go to the wikipedia or they go to some
kind of scientific dictionary or
encyclopedia
and that's
the wrong place to look for it okay
why don't you do it the scientific way
right and look for it in a book of
physics
get any textbook of physics on the
planet
uh from the past or from the present
even from the future
and i want you to look for the word
motion and for the word object see if
you find them defined
anywhere in any textbook on earth of
physics
okay then you can show to me that you
have a scientific definition but to say
you go to the dictionary well you go to
addiction it's a it's from ordinary
speech the people who write dictionaries
are
uh english majors or librarians they're
not scientists and what the physicists
so-called mathematical physics is
mathematicians do they go to the
ordinary dictionary and you say okay
there i found what an object is i found
what science what motion is
and then they put that into
encyclopedias like the wikipedia or or
whatever scientific wiki
encyclopedia
and then you find it there and say oh
there's a scientific definition now that
science so-called scientific definition
came from the ordinary
dictionary which came from librarians
who have no stake in physics
now if you're if you're honest with
yourself
show me a book of physics
so-called physics the ones that they
teach in high school and college
any textbook
i'll buy you a beer if you can come up
with one book any textbook
that begins by defining the word object
with which i without which you can't do
physics you can't do physics without an
object just look for a book
that has the word object defined and
then the word motion and no you won't
find it you won't find the word motion
anywhere not defined like
motion
uh colon and this is the definition you
won't find it okay so everybody's
essentially relying on good old
aristotle who said that it's too
uh it's a change in position a change of
place and changes a synonym of motion so
we have a circular definition we have
synonyms that's all we have
okay so uh what is this uh
uh motion time what is all this stuff
and you know when when uh people want to
illustrate
time
what they do is usually draw a line
an align with an arrow because they say
it increases in that direction
one second two seconds three second ten
seconds one hour you know time increases
in a given direction so they put in a a
a line and they put an arrow head at the
end of that line they're going to be
using cartesian coordinates right
most of you were familiar with those
notions and this is what they uh they
draw it says
oh no one person says
this is where time also comes in what
falls is if there is motion we have time
involved
well um no not true
when there is time you have motion
involved but not in reverse you can have
motion without time okay and again let's
show that okay here it is
this is how they illustrate time usually
they put an error and they say that's
time okay and time increases or whatever
towards the right in this case okay but
this is how it's illustrated
okay the problem is that uh what you're
staring at is not time right now you
have no comparison with anything so how
do you know how many seconds went by or
whatever
okay what you have there if anything you
have motion that's what you have that's
what you have there you have motion
okay so if you draw a single arrow
you're not illustrating time you're
illustrating motion okay so let's
replace that time with motion okay
that's what we have
okay so we have motion and um
there seems to be a little bit of
problem there but uh first let's look at
time here's time okay if motion is a
single arrow what is time well time is
two arrows it's a comparison of two
motions okay you need two motions to
compare them once again one against the
other in order to come up with time
okay but again we still have a problem
why because uh that does not really
illustrate
something important and that's uh what
uh aristotle said and that that and
that's that the arrows have to be
segmented you have to
chop them into pieces because you're
going to talk about motion being made of
locations and here it is you have to
have locations you have to have motion
two or more locations of an object
that's where you start and then you have
time which is
a comparison of two motions
and for that you're gonna need
you're gonna need memory you need
someone to memorize all that stuff okay
but uh what do we have if you have
locations
uh you know you're saying okay if you
have like the universal movie what i
call the universal movie
for every frame in that movie all you
have in each frame of that movie is
location
and this is how i illustrate it here
okay here you have mother nature and
she's in a film okay and you have mother
nature all she has is one location at a
time in each frame okay
you heard of movies what are movies well
movies are uh motion pictures you have
pictures in motion why are they in
motion because you have many frames and
it gives you the
impression that there is some action
going on on the screen but in order to
have a film you need to have you know
many frames and each frame only has
location
objects just at a given distance from
each other when you take the set of
locations the set of distances from one
object to the to all others you have
location and that's all you have in uh
in one frame of those films okay
okay so uh
um what you have is this movie of
mother nature there and that whole film
strip it just occupies a little piece of
strip you know a little strip there of
uh of that movie and what you have on
one side and the other those black marks
those are just locations all you have
within each one which is what you can
call a cross-section of time a
cross-section of motion all you have is
location just one location static
concepts okay we're going to build we're
going to construct motion with many
locations okay and it looks more or less
like this
okay here you see it okay
and
what is time in this context well what
you have
for time is that you're comparing two
motions
what are you comparing well
just an example here okay you have the
tick marks on your clock
and that's the second hand okay the one
that counts seconds and it goes from one
tick mark to the next
by the time it went from one tick mark
to the next maybe it's just a one
millimeter uh
uh trip that's that's the distance
traveled
the earth meanwhile traveled 30
kilometers
okay now you can chop that film strip of
one millimeter in one case and 30
kilometers in the other okay you can
chop it as much as you want
for the universal movie uh all we had
was load one location at a time for
every object in the entire universe
every object in the entire universe just
had one location with respect to each
other for a one frame of the universal
movie and you can make that frame as
small as you want it doesn't matter
you're gonna have one frame only and all
you have is a static image with every
object just uh far away from each other
that's all you have
and so
so that second hand there the one that
moved one millimeter right
it has to match
uh the distance of the earth and
traveled so uh if if i were to cut that
film the universal movie film right into
um
frames one frame only all i would see in
that frame is the second hand at a
certain location and the earth at a
second location with respect to the sun
obviously right and if i go to another
frame i'm gonna find a different
location for the second hand and a
different location for the earth but
they have to match because one second
equals 30 kilometers what you're doing
is comparing the the motion of the earth
against the motion of the second hand on
your watch that's what it is and that's
what time is so you need two motions if
you only have what you see on the top
just one
dotted line okay then you do not have
time all you have is motion
okay so
we distinguish motion from time motion
just requires one line with a bunch of
locations
time
you don't you still don't have time you
want time you need two motions
and you need memory okay you need an
observer for time that's why time has
nothing to do with science we don't use
time and science it's only the religious
people of mathematics the mathematicians
they're the ones who put in time because
they want to describe things they want
to put a number in an equation we have
no use for any of that okay we have no
use for time whatsoever in science in
science we have to explain why what
causes this pencil to fall to the floor
i don't need to know how much time it
took
not important not relevant
all i need to show is the mechanism of
what brought that pencil down to the
earth
okay so um um
let's look at here uh subject matter
which we started today and that relates
to this subject okay here's called the
present
now people say well where does the
present belong are we talking about
motion are we talking about time what
are we talking about is the present a
static concept are we talking about
location
is present related to location to motion
or to time what is the present related
to that's the question
and so let's go through step by step
present is a cross section of time it's
a pre present is the cross section of
motion
what was the cross section of motion
location
so when you talk about the now you talk
about the meeting of the past with the
present
okay so you have the movie of the past
everything that happened in the past the
movie of the future right
past in the future
and
in between squeezed within there in a
single frame you have the present the
now
what is the present the noun location
that's where mother nature exists she
exists in the present location only
there is no motion okay she's in a
single frame of the universal movie and
then she moves on to the next frame next
frame next frame and builds this movie
called the universal movie everything
moving in the universe
but for one frame all we have is
location that is known as the now
that's known as the known as the present
so the present really has nothing to do
with time or with motion has to do with
location okay
present uh not equal to two locations
the present is a single frame in the
film only one location
okay and um you can't use the word
instant to refer to um the present
because people
many times use oh it was instantaneous
or it's instant instant coffee
how long did it take you to make that
instant coffee you know
instantaneous
is a notion that
confuses people because people think
instantaneous and they're saying oh okay
it happened so rapidly that i could not
even measure it that's the notion they
have but see instantaneous involves an
interval if it's time and instantaneous
only belongs to time
they're talking about an interval of
time because time can only be an
interval there is no such thing as
really a cross section of time and
cross-section of motion because now
you're talking about a static concept
you're talking about
the now the present what location
okay so we have to distinguish that in
physics location from motion not to
mention time which we have no use for
okay
okay so the present is not equal to
distance traveled it's not equal to um
two locations it's equal to
distance separation
okay and many separations many distances
that's what we call location all those
are static concepts all those should
appear in a single frame of the
universal movie okay so the present is
equal to location uh present meeting
between the past and the future but
present is not equal to an interval it's
not
instantaneous
the present okay so we have to
understand the concepts here we have to
understand what location motion and time
are from a conceptual point of view
okay uh here we have a
rerun
quick rerun i didn't put area in there
uh
the iliatics talked about the other day
and they said there is no motion no such
thing as motion
and they said because uh for that you
would have to have the void exist in
order for something to occupy the void
okay which is what aristotle is going to
say
and um and so they went through this
reasoning saying there is no motion and
the uh atomos you know like uh
democritus and lucipus uh they said you
guys are crazy yeah here's motion i'm
moving my hand okay so don't tell me
there's no motion okay so it was like um
something again uh what is it
gaslighting
the guy's saying it's a fact there is no
emotion what do you mean here's motion
this is a fact
they all really believed in different
facts okay and they're staring at motion
they say
i don't believe you i don't believe
there's motion okay no he doesn't define
motion because he says everybody knows
what it is and we get all the way to mr
heisenberg you know we're in her
heisenberg and he says when the ball
moves it doesn't stand still when it
stands still it doesn't move known as
the uncertainty principle
says poppycock this is what these people
got a degree for to say such stupid
things as that that the more you know
about position the less you know about
motion the more you know about motion
the less you know about position
yeah no kidding did you have to go to
the university to figure that out did
you need an equation to figure that out
okay so here are the conclusions okay
for motion okay run uh
through these uh
different aspects of it motion two is
two locations that's what motion is what
is time time is a comparison of two
motions you require memory you need an
observer and therefore we have no use
for time in science let alone in physics
okay time belongs exclusively to the
religion of mathematics because they
need to put a value in an equation okay
mother nature has no idea of time
mother nature has no idea of motion mine
mother nature exists in the present
she only exists now for every frame of
the universal movie okay
exist uh
you need to have location it's a static
concept okay you need an object with
location uh what is present location so
what you see in in the universal movie
in a single frame is what exists
and that's all that mother nature
understands okay
the present is a cross-section of time
of motion also uh you can look at it
that way okay we're talking about a
single location okay and present is a
single frame of the universal movie
okay now uh
aristotle said well motion is continuous
because um you know it's infinite and
it's continuous and in continuous means
you can chop it up into little locations
or
voids or
places as he called them or at least
translated as such
he said time is continuous again you can
chop it into little seconds and that
means that
you have these units
and
they had this notion of location that's
what uh they chopped time and motion
into discrete locations okay
but
if motion
if is continuous made of
according to aristotle right made of
discrete locations we have a problem
because an object is what is discrete
you can say an object has surface it's
that which has shape and therefore is
discrete
location is a concept locations do not
have shape they don't have uh size they
don't have anything it's a concept so
it's irrational to say that location is
discrete
okay you don't make concepts discrete
only objects can be discrete physically
discrete in science in physics okay
location is a concept so you cannot say
that it's discrete
so
location
is a set of distances to an object and
you can take it from the surface or from
the center of the object it's up to you
that's arbitrary but the point here is
that
um time is uh motion is made of
locations
but uh the location is not discrete
okay so it's continuous why because
location itself is not discrete okay so
this is where aristotle failed no one
figured that out in 10 000 years okay
yeah you have to differentiate between
objects and concepts objects is that
which is discrete low concepts cannot be
discrete at all so you cannot talk about
motion being made of pieces
okay so this is where the problem is
okay no origin to motion this is another
issue nobody created motion
the single thread has always been there
no origin to the single thread therefore
no origin to atoms and no creation of
matter
like in mathematical physics
specifically in um
general relativity
which they say you know there was this
big bang that created matter
uh
how do you create something from nothing
i don't know but that's what they do in
not only in general relativity but they
do it also in quantum mechanics you know
you have particles coming in from the
void meaning the void is made out of
particles and it turns out that the void
itself space was created at the big bang
meaning before that there was no space
so what was there
nothing what a space i thought space was
nothing and so again you get this run
around from the establishment because
they never solved that in fact they say
it's beyond uh
uh science that that's unscientific
that's philosophy or something you know
out there
so they have this theory that you know
the universe started at the big bang
meaning matter was created the big bang
space was created at the big bang time
itself was greedy and the big bang and
so you say well what was there before
that
and they say
don't ask that question it's an
unscientific question because we cannot
test the hypothesis
okay
so that's your answer
okay let's move on to some of the
questions people made
let's see we got
one fella he says
natural geometry
natural geometry what is this natural
geometry mathematics wasn't made by man
oh okay who was it made by a god
we discovered learned the language of
the universe and light
okay you discovered learned
i don't know if discovering is learning
okay learning i guess you read a book
you open a book and memorize what
someone else wrote but you say someone
discovered it
what did you discover discovered what uh
universe and light what is it the
language of universe and light
yeah you discover what's out there what
does that mean did mother nature invent
numbers
or did you create numbers and establish
the relations
see mother nature doesn't do relations
she just moves one object from one one
location to the next that's all she does
in her entire life that's all that
father universe does that's all that i
guess god in the devil do all they do is
move one object to the next location
that's all they do that's all they
understand
okay that's that's all that is out there
we
people who have
some people who have too much
intelligence right
and they go out there and they say oh i
can establish a relationship i see a
pattern here and they say the pattern
was there
and mother nature just wanted to give us
us to a hint and we had to discover this
secret
it's like uh the easter egg you gotta
find out where the easter egg is and
they say oh it's so exciting i'm gonna
find out all these relations that are
out there that mother nature made and
that she hides from us and we have to
somehow discover
through uh looking to
observing through running tests or
whatever measuring
and so this is the notion these people
have no mother nature has no relations
no nothing we make the relations we
created math okay so he says science
physics is the study of nature and how
the universe functions yeah and that's
got nothing to do with numbers okay
because how because you can interpret
the word how any which way you want okay
how could be
um
a
how meaning a description of something
how something happened a car crashed
another against another you say two cars
crashed
that's a howl
but then you can also say well how did
it happen
well one was running down the street and
it hit the other car so now you're
explaining how the thing happened and
these are not the same things you know
one is one type of power and the other
one is another type of how okay so here
you have mother nature and uh yeah she's
uh
uh weaving the rope
okay that's what she does
and all she does is just have these
ropes all around the universe
okay that's all she does so to say that
uh
she invented numbers no she never went
to school okay
and here it is okay
here's the uh analysis mother nature
never went to school she doesn't know
what math is
so don't tell me that you know that uh
mother nature invented math and we just
discovered the math no no it's the other
way around mother nature never has
anything whatsoever to do with math it's
us that establish their relations
and she never learned equations or
numbers uh dear mama only works with
objects she places them in different
locations in different frames of the
universal movie that's all she does
it is humans who invented relations and
quantified them okay
and if you go to another uh you're going
to land of the klingons i'm sure they
have different values they don't have
feet inches and meters they don't need
or kilograms or seconds no they probably
have um different units over there and
so they're going to find different
patterns you know some people are
fascinated by numbers they say 3 6 nine
or you know six six six and they see
patterns and they go nuts over all these
numbers
you're gonna land on the klingons and
over there seven seven seven
or two four six eight you know who knows
so the so all these patterns that these
people see is because because you know
they just get fascinated they are
mystics they believe in all these
supernatural things that's all they are
okay fella says
sorry about hypothesis here says
hypothesis recorded since 1596 base
supposition literally a placing under a
set before to suggest short version
hypothesis equal rational base argument
to be built upon to explain a phenomena
okay um well we got a problem with this
for several reasons and here's the
breakdown okay first of all uh we clean
our nose holes with etymology okay there
is we don't care about etymology because
that only has to do with tradition
uh we have changed definitions
throughout history that's one issue the
other one is that if they had it wrong
from the start you're not going to keep
doing it wrong forever at some point you
say well that definition was started out
wrong okay so we have the wrong
definition or an irrational definition
of the word object then we have to
change it and we have the wrong
definition or irrational definition of
what motion is we have to change that as
well we can't say well this is how they
do how aristotle defined motion we have
to continue with that because that's
what motion is now we find out that
aristotle wasn't very smart then we wipe
out his definition we replaced the word
motion for science purpose again
with the rational definition
and here you have an example does
supposition refer to an object a
description of an object or to a
tentative
theory what are we talking about is a
supposition
a narrative that you talk about
something something that happened or are
you saying let us assume that the sky is
black
you know that's like pointing to
something and saying it's black or white
or whatever that's different type of
supposition than saying let us assume uh
her husband murdered the wife okay those
are different suppositions so we need to
find out what a supposition is and it
turns out that they never defined
rational this guy uses rational base
argument right
and they never define supposition so we
don't know what these words mean anyways
and to say that you know hypothesis is a
supposition you said absolutely nothing
all you gave is a synonym
okay
and uh yeah we do have a definition for
hypothesis okay and we're going to get
to that in a minute here
and so here's another file says a belief
has absolutely no credence in the
scientific method maybe even contrary
okay a hypothesis is a belief
no absolutely not a hypothesis is not a
belief and opinion okay hypothesis is an
assumption it's supposition
what is a supposition what is a
hypothesis well there's several elements
one is that it's the
set of assumptions and they include the
objects that you're going to present in
physics this is all for physics
the objects you're going to present the
ones that are going to uh be the actors
in your theory you've got to present
those otherwise people don't know what
you're talking about you can say uh god
made the universe
okay where's god oh i don't know
well what do you mean you don't know
you're talking about a physical theory
you're saying that it created all the
matter out there the atoms etc and
you're saying you don't know what
created that
what is it that created it what's the
mechanism before you have the mechanism
you have to show me god
you're going to say nothing created
everything i mean you know so you need
the objects first word that you have to
define in physics the word object you
can't do physics without object then you
need the definitions you know what
definition are you going to use to make
your theory okay if you're going to say
that an object is that which you can see
your touch well that's easily debunked
so you can't use that irrational
definition you can't say it's just a
bunch of matter because that's also
irrational okay
and so all you can do is go to the
scientific definition that would just
shape
can you make your case with that
definition if you can't well then you
gotta fight first for the definition of
the word object before you make your
case you haven't even started with your
assumptions those are assumptions and
then you have the statement of the facts
i discussed that uh briefly today uh
statement of the facts we don't know the
facts especially that's something that
happened which is what science is trying
to explain you know what happened how
something happened
how did gravity happen
you know what causes
the earth to remain faithful to the sun
we need to find out what happened how it
does that magic trick and for that you
make a statement of the facts
let us assume that all atoms are
physically interconnected then from that
assumption now you proceed to your
theory that's the way it works now you
can follow the person but to say you
know uh
what space time well what do you mean
where space time what do you mean bent
time
how are you gonna explain it with bend
time what kind of assumption is that
what kind of supposition is that is that
a hypothesis
you know and so again you need to define
these terms in order to follow the
presenter you need to know you know what
the guy's talking about or understand
what he's talking about
okay here we have another fellow and he
asked something else again related to
hypothesis a couple questions on
hypothesis this time around a hypothesis
is a theoretical explanation
that needs further exploration
no a hypothesis is not an explanation
that's what the mathematicians taught
you
okay by wrote you learned it by road you
just memorized you never questioned it
that's the issue hypothesis is not a
theory or an explanation hypothesis is
an assumption
a supposition what are you supposing
well the objects the definitions and you
make a statement over the facts the
defense attorney has a different
statement of the
of what happened
uh than the prosecutor they start off
different assumptions
okay
and it's okay you don't have to believe
one or the other what you do is you
listen you concede the assumption the
supposition in order to understand their
case their theory what is the theory
based on that assumption okay
that's what it's all about
okay another fellow says
a theory may not be correct
well a theory is never correct it's
never correct incorrect true or false
theories are never correct or incorrect
it's irrational to say that a theory is
correct or incorrect that's religion
in science a a theory
is either rational or irrational okay so
you don't have false or true
what is it
theories
what you have is rational or or
irrational if it's irrational it doesn't
belong in science
only irrational theories belong in
science okay
and mathematical physics only has
irrational definitions
i'm sorry theories explanations
what i went over a couple of uh warped
space-time
they don't know what an atom looks like
or why the
electron doesn't fly out of the atom uh
magnetism you have the electron beads
spinning in each cart
the watermelons right
and uh how do the carts attract each
other well they'll never explain to you
they just say oh the
watermelon spin
right yeah
irrational is equal to the movement of
concepts that's what irrational is
primarily so if you're going to move a
concept such as field as energy as mass
as time you're going to warp it right
with gravity another concept if you're
going to do that you're moving concepts
around
and when you move abstract concepts well
it means you had one beard too many
that's what it means okay you're an
irrational individual and you don't
belong in science and that means that
every phd in mathematical physics today
should quit
science
none of them are scientists their phds
are worthless pieces of paper
okay
if they're going to be investigating
dark matter black holes big bang
particle being at two places at once
their degrees are worthless garbage
okay just as simple as that so the fact
that oh he he knows all that math who
cares
he memorized all the math right that
newton and all the way to einstein
invented and they just read it and they
understand it great like saying i'm
going to learn chinese i know chinese
does that make you a scientist because
you know how to speak this language
known as chinese
what is math it's an it's a language and
so you learn this language you know how
to play around it
and you know how to describe things with
those uh hieroglyphics
does that make you a scientist because
you can describe things
uh with equations
what does that have to do with science
with explaining a mechanism okay which
is what we want to understand
if we want to understand how the
universe works why it works that way why
it works the way it does
why does gravity work the way it does
that's what we want to understand you
don't understand that you're not a
physicist
all you are as a mathematician all
you're doing is putting an equation and
describing that you know the pencil
falls at 9.8 meters per second square
here on earth and 1 6 of that over there
on the moon great
you know what is that
just description okay another follow
says uh it's irrational to invent
substances
okay i don't know what that really means
we only need what already exists
everywhere okay what is it he says it's
present in all matter in between atoms
in our atmosphere in our solar system
the rope
see somebody likes the rope no he says
it's called something called plasma
plasma he says plasma permeates the
universe it's everywhere
between the earth and the sun and then
he says electricity electrostatics is
gravity it connects all matter
so uh well poor fellow i mean you know i
really feel sorry for him but so what do
we do well
we we put this up there so he
understands uh where these words like
electricity and plasma belong okay i'm
going to try to see if you can find the
word somewhere okay
these are the words that idiots use an
idiot is an enlightened person a very
bright person right extremely bright
person with very big ideas
and those are the words that idiots
usually use to make their case and i
don't know it's gonna take it's gonna
take them a while to find but uh you
should be able to find some of the words
he used in there okay
so uh
yeah if he uh thinks that uh
you know there's this plasma thingy
between
uh any two atoms and that electricity
connects the universe you know
it connects all matter you know how does
it connect it
uh what is electricity a bunch of
electrons flowing from one atom to
another i mean i don't know maybe he's
got a different notion of electricity
the notion that they have in the
religion of quantum mechanics is that
it's an electron beat that moves from
atom to atom how that connects
physically binds the entire universe i
have no idea he's got to explain that a
little ball rolling from atom to atom
and it pulls on atoms on the other side
of the universe it causes gravity you
tug of the andromeda galaxy to the milky
way galaxy
yeah sure please simulate it in the lab
you know let's test your hypothesis
throw some stones at something and show
me how you pull on that thing okay
that's what you got to do
okay another file says and this guy won
the contest for this week for the idiot
okay of the week on a roll so
he won guys you can should congratulate
him
anyone can come up with an explanation
okay anyone okay
what's your proposal
uh your proposed mechanism for gravity
anyone okay i mean do you have a are you
just saying this because the air is free
and say anyone can do that okay so
anyone
uh please show us what is your mechanism
for gravity
okay so if you say anyone can come up
with it okay uh do it anyone sounds like
uh who was it odysseus uh when he landed
in the land of the uh
cyclops and he enters this uh cave and
um the cyclops wants to kill him and he
removes his eye you know he's uh so the
cyclops cannot see
and so the cyclops
is shouting says what is your name who
are you and he says something like this
though i'm anyone he said i'm no one
that's what he said and so when other
cyclops came to the cave and heard him
shouting in there said what's wrong with
you
says oh they took my eye they blinded me
and who did it
no one no one did it oh and they said oh
okay they just left
and that's the same guy anyone he came
from the land of the cyclops okay every
explanation is based on assumptions such
as how imaginary rogues might actually
behave
well yes and no see the word how is
tricky there you could be referring to a
description statement of the facts or
you could be referring as a how to a
theory to an explanation so you got to
clarify what you mean by how that's
where the trick is okay
and then he says experiments are
necessary to find out if the explanation
that makes
um sense in your head has any
relationship to reality
okay so
what experiment did this poor suffering
individual
you know what experiment does he propose
to identify the invisible intangible you
know here we have it again one more time
invisible intangible
uh things that are causing gravity
uh
what's he gonna use what experiment are
we going to do what does he propose
and i get tired of asking these people
they just say oh you need to run an
experiment
okay tell me what experiment i need to
run to detect to find out what's here or
here because something came in contact
with the skin of the pen
aside from my fingers now right when i
let go of this
hey it goes down
so i'm holding it up but you say well
it's held up because your fingers are
touching the pencil they're holding it
up against its will
okay great you're right but as soon as i
let go something else is pulling it down
or pushing it down up from from above no
problem i have no problem with that as
long as you have a mechanism show us our
your mechanism then we can criticize it
so what does he propose to detect these
invisible
entities are coming in contact with the
skin of the pen
what
experiment does he propose to come in
contact
comes in contact um you know or what
object what things come in contact with
the skin of the earth that prevent it
from flying out of the solar system i
mean uh
um
i'm sorry general relativity says it's
warped time
so uh that's kind of weird you know warp
time but yeah you can imagine the
mechanism a roulette mechanism the earth
cannot leave the solar system because
there's a curved wall of time but it's
the curved wall of time which doesn't
pass the test the
suppositions known as the hypothesis
okay that's the one that doesn't pass
okay
and um
this fellow continues i think it's the
same i don't know it says how does an
electromagnetic rope differ from an
ordinary nylon rope
i ask you to explain why the ropes
contract and you pull out newton's
equation
i thought math had nothing to do with
physics
poor fellow poor fellow
uh anyways now the ropes don't contract
okay it's made of
the
thread the
universal thread single thread as we
call it made of a single piece
it's flexible okay
and makes up the ropes and the atoms
that are interconnected by the ropes so
there's a single thread making up all
matter in the universe and but the issue
here is you know he says i thought math
had nothing to do with physics
he doesn't understand the definition
between an explanation and a description
so all you can do fellow is go out there
and look for
several videos that i have on
explanation description and you'll find
your answer okay
okay with that uh i'll see you next time
i'll see you on sunday bye